[Music]
can we hear a Bigfoot call I understand
you do a Bigfoot call they do they make
all kinds of calls but I just do this
one we think it's like a adult male call
a clonk like what they're looking for
each other of a long distance but it
goes like
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to be honest with you you're
describing thousands of these creatures
that live in the woods and scream about
all the times like Robin Williams in a
bear trap we don't have any footage of
zember we don't have one how come we
don't have one
there's footage why don't we have one
why isn't he on the show right now
why isn't he on the view why isn't he
walking around I mean because then Bobo
would never show yeah well my show be
number one if that happens well are you
curious at all about if you do get
Bigfoot let's say you finally you're out
in the woods you're yelling Bigfoot was
running without him come around so we've
got audio recordings of them not talking
about that man I'm talking about you've
got Bigfoot manacled to your wrist you
have him right are you gonna what you
gonna do when you finally catch me gonna
take them on tour you're gonna bring
them around I have no I know I mean I
don't want to see him caught it I want
to see him in his I think they're just
fine out cruising around I'd like to
fill them and I think when the DNA comes
out that they're gonna there would be a
lot of money pours into it and they're
gonna you know have like there's smaller
and smaller cameras you can hide out in
the woods now you know it's a matter of
time before we see Bigfoot technology's
catching up Joe right I thought the moon
was made of cheese